He had been pacing back and forth all night,
so many hours spent walking to and fro in
his quarters that his feet were starting to
develop painful blisters.
Yet Jace couldn’t bring himself to stay
still after his unsettling discovery.
Over the course of the night, it had driven
him almost mad.
But it wasn’t just the fear of the inevitable
calamity he had learned of that was keeping
him up, and worrying him into a state of near
insanity.
It was the lie, the smokescreen that had been
used to cover up the truth… and it came
all the way from the top.
Jace Jacobi had been working as a researcher
within the SCP Foundation for the better part
of a decade.
Sure, it wasn’t an easy job at the best
of times; in fact, it could be dirty, dangerous,
and even downright deadly work.
But Jace had learned to take comfort in the
bigger picture, and it cultivated in him a
loyalty for the Foundation and what they stood
for.
The reassuring knowledge that he was playing
but one small part in protecting the world
from anomalous threats usually helped him
sleep a little easier at night.
This was not one of those nights.
Completely by accident, the researcher had
learned of a terrible truth.
He’d seen a lot of horrible things while
working at the Foundation, from one horrific,
endlessly regenerating omnicidal reptile
to a monstrous creature comprised primarily
of giant teeth protruding from its body.
But what he had uncovered in the depths of
the SCP Foundation’s own archive, terrified
him for a whole different reason: because
it seemed to undo every good thing Jace and
all other personnel had done the name of the
Foundation.
He believed that they were the good guys,
that their efforts were to prevent total global
destruction.
Instead, it turned out they were just pawns.
Being familiar with a whole filing cabinet’s
worth of special containment procedures for
various anomalies, Jace was familiar with
the term ‘220 Calabasas’.
He’d even almost been considered to receive
high enough security clearance to be given
the full details as to what it entailed.
He was aware already that was the name given
to a process that was required to be performed
by Foundation staff, as a way to keep SCP-2317
actively contained.
SCP-2317 was a wooden door leading to another
dimension.
Or at least, it appeared to be.
After accessing some restricted files, a suppressed
secondary level of information hidden underneath
the SCP-2317 entry, Jace discovered what was
really going on.
SCP-2317 was – in part – a Door to Another
World, as its nickname suggested.
But that wasn’t the whole story.
Beyond the door lay a barren salt plain, the
only structures visible for miles being seven
identical stone pillars with ancient symbols
carved into their surface.
Frequently, a small group of Foundation personnel
and security staff would be sent into SCP-2317,
each one of them given a specific role to
undertake as they performed 220 Calabasas.
That process required for active containment
was more like an occult ritual, involving
holy water, an obsidian-edged knife, chants
that invoked ancient powerful gods, and a
chicken to act as a live sacrifice.
If Jace had just learned those specifics of
220 Calabasas, he wouldn’t have realized
that the ritual was actually a phony, even
a pretty convincing one at that.
Buried beneath the pillars was chained something
of unspeakable, unknowable power.
It had gone by many names, each invoking a
particularly nasty sense of trepidation.
The Sire of Tyranny, Qiral Erîbav, or simply
the Devourer of Worlds.
The 220 Calabasas ritual was supposedly a
way to keep the beast locked below, to strengthen
the seven chains each latching the ancient
monstrosity to the pillars above.
Except it didn’t; it was a smokescreen,
the ritual did nothing to keep the shackles
of the Devourer intact.
There was but one chain remaining, one more
tether keeping the ancient beast caged.
And over the years, no matter how many times
the Foundation performed 220 Calabasas, it
was eroding, getting weaker and weaker.
It was inevitable: the Devourer of Worlds
would one day be free.
And yet, that wasn’t even the worst part
about what Jace had uncovered.
What could possibly be worse than learning
an eldritch deity intent on unfurling doom
couldn’t be contained with the one method
the Foundation had?
Well, it was that the Foundation knew and
had known for a long time that 220 Calabasas
was nothing more than a charade, with all
the effectiveness of a band-aid over a broken
leg.
As if that wasn’t bad enough, Jace had traced
the source of this cover-up right to the very
top, to the highest operational level within
the SCP Foundation’s hierarchy; the O5 Council
was responsible.
They had known for a long, long time about
the ineffectiveness of 220 Calabasas, and
yet hadn’t pursued any more permanent solutions
to the looming threat posed by SCP-2317 and
the Devourer.
After a sleepless night, Jace could hold it
in no longer.
He had to tread carefully, given how far up
the chain this conspiracy went, it was hard
to know who to trust.
Something had to be done, that much was clear
to him, whether that involved sealing or outright
destroying SCP-2317.
But if those tasked with overseeing the entire
Foundation were in on this cover up, then
Jace had to be extremely careful about who
he went to for help.
There was only one person he was certain he
could rely on, and share his findings with
in secrecy.
Senior Researcher Ellis had long been a good
friend of Jace’s; in fact, he’d even go
as far to say that Ellis was his only real
friend within the Foundation.
The more experienced member of personnel had
practically mentored Jacobi from his earliest
days as an SCP researcher.
Ellis had helped him get to grips with certain
difficult containment procedures, and even
taken the fall for Jace after some of his
early mistakes nearly caused a containment
breach.
Researcher Ellis’ seniority meant he only
got away with a metaphorical slap on the wrist.
But most crucially for Jace right now, Ellis
wasn’t a high enough rank to be even close
to any of the upper echelon Foundation doctors
like Doctor Bright or Doctor Gears.
Nor was he senior enough to have any direct
dealings with the O5 Council.
If there was anyone working at the Foundation
that Jace could possibly confide in about
his findings regarding the truth behind SCP-2317
and 220 Calabasas, it was Ellis.
And maybe, between them, the pair could put
their heads together and avert the catastrophe
of the Devourer’s inevitable escape.
Jace was nervously pacing back and forth while
Ellis’ eyes were glued to the terminal in
his quarters.
He had shown him a saved copy of the full
archive entry on SCP-2317, detailing everything.
Not just the steps required to perform 220
Calabasas, but the additional information
at the ritual didn’t work, and that the
O5 Council knew it.
After a long, painful wait for Researcher
Ellis to scan through the entire file, he
leaned back from the terminal screen and sighed.
“Well, this is hardly ideal,” he stated
matter-of-factly.
“Hardly ideal?”
Jace echoed, his fear of what this all meant
manifesting itself as a frustrated outburst.
“I think you might be underestimating it
just a little there, Ellis!
This isn’t just some mild inconvenience
we’ve now got to live with, we’re talking
about the end of the world as we know it!
XK-Class!
And on top of that, the Council know it’s
coming and are doing nothing about it!
Instead, they’re making these high clearance
personnel go and pointlessly slaughter chickens
and recite meaningless prayers about ‘Seven
Seals, Seven Rings, Seven Thrones for The
Scarlet King’.”
“Jacobi, calm down,” Ellis replied sternly.
“Let’s talk about this rationally.
For all we know, this file here could be a
part of SCP-2317’s containment procedures.”
“That’s what I’m saying, the procedure
is ineffective!”
he argued.
“Let me finish,” the senior researcher
responded calmly.
“We know of dozens of other anomalies that
employ infohazardous or memetic effects.
And sometimes, it’s not uncommon for entities
of such a nature, with capabilities to infect
information itself to be combated via the
use of deliberate, necessary misinformation.
This file might not even be an accurate description
of SCP-2317, it could easily be a method for
containing something else.”
“No, that doesn’t…”
Jace paused, holding his forehead.
“Sorry, all of this is giving me a headache.
Could I trouble you for some water?”
“Of course,” Ellis answered.
He got up from his seat and filled a plastic
cup from a cooler in his quarters.
While his back was turned, Jacobi didn’t
see Ellis slip something into the water.
“Thanks, Ellis,” Jace said as he gulped
down the whole cupful.
“Like I was saying, that theory of it being
a memetic threat doesn’t make sense.
You’ve seen SCP-2317 from a distance.
We both have.
It’s a physical dimensional gateway; I mean,
‘A Door to Another World’ is literally
its codename, for god’s sake!
Why would there be a real door with an intangible
infohazard behind it?”
Ellis stroked his chin, pondering quietly.
For a moment, Jace’s vision seemed to get
a little blurry, but he blinked it away.
“Okay, so if we take everything in the SCP-2317
file as gospel, then answer me this: what
do you propose we do about it?”
his mentor asked.
“We have to think, radically.
Together I think you and I need to come up
with an alternate, permanent solution to the
impending threat posed by SCP-2317.
Then, we present it to the O5 Council, storm
into their chamber if necessary, and demand
them to implement it.
The next 220 Calabasas is scheduled for a
few hours from now.
We need to bring them something that will
actually work, not just that performative
pantomime they put on as a smokescreen.
Otherwise, Ellis…”
Jace paused a moment, hearing his own voice
crack with despair, “If we don’t, the
Devourer is going to destroy everything.”
“You said the words permanent solution,
elaborate for me, please,” Ellis responded.
“Look, I think we have only two options,”
the frightened researcher said; Jace noticed
he was starting to feel drowsy, lightheaded
even, needing to shake himself to stay upright
and conscious.
“We either find a way to seal SCP-2317,
or we destroy the Door to Another World outright.
The 220 Calabasas procedure…
no, ritual?
Rit…-ual.
They take a one kiloton nuke in with them
in case of containment failure, right?
We detonate one of those inside that dimension,
pray that it kills the Devourer of Words…
Worlds.
Then, we shut the door and blow that up behind
us too…”
Suddenly, Jace’s legs gave out underneath
him, like they couldn’t support his bodyweight
anymore.
He landed on the floor with a thud, while
Ellis loomed over him with a sympathetic look
on his lined face.
“You… drug…
me?”
Jace barely managed to get the question out.
“I’m sorry, Jacobi,” Ellis sighed.
“Believe me when I say that I would have
preferred to talk you out of these seditious
thoughts.
But duty to the Foundation comes first.
You understand.”
The door opened, the heavy clomping of boots
against the floor.
Jace could barely turn to see the squad of
security guards entering the room.
They lifted his body up off the ground, getting
limper by the second, and began dragging him
out by his arms.
With all his waning strength, he kicked and
thrashed his legs as they trailed beneath
him.
Being taken away by the guards, Jace yelled
for his mentor’s help.
He kept trying until his voice became slurred,
imperceptible sounds, not even words anymore.
The world around him started sinking into
darkness as whatever he’d been dosed with
took full effect.
As Jace was hauled off struggling, not once
did Ellis dare to look him in the eye.
Jace had no idea how much time had passed,
only that he’d been chemically knocked unconscious
for most of it.
Opening his heavy eyelids, he had no idea
where he was: the room around him was in pitch
darkness.
For a second, he wondered if he’d been executed
by the Foundation, and was currently dead,
his consciousness trapped in an endless, inky
void.
Then another concerning thought pushed its
way into his head; had they thrown him into
the Devourer of Worlds’ prison?
It was a cruel, callous move – even for
the SCP Foundation – to offer Jace up as
a sacrifice for daring to look further into
the truth behind SCP-2317.
A column of light cut through the dark from
somewhere above him, gleaming down so bright
that it was hard to look directly at it.
The spotlight did little to illuminate the
rest of the room, although squinting through
the dark, the researcher could detect the
outlines of several figures sat in a circle,
facing him.
Thirteen of them, to be exact, with one extra
taking their seat.
He was just awake enough to remember a crucial
detail that explained where he was: there
were thirteen members of the O5 Council, along
with one Administrator.
“Hello again, Researcher Jacobi,” came
a voice from one of the seats encircling him.
“Tell us, do you know why you’re here?”
“Y-you…”
Jace stuttered, before his fear once again
erupted in an explosive outburst.
“You all knew about SCP-2317!
You had us perform 220 Calabasas time and
time again, knowing that it was doing nothing
to keep the Devourer contained.
If that creature gets loose…
no, when it does, it will destroy everything
and everyone.
The Foundation is meant to contain anomalies,
not pretend to!
We have a duty to every adult and child on
this planet to protect them from this entity.”
“Do not exposit the Foundation’s mandates
to us, Jacobi,” another of the councilmember’s
voices replied, sounding not in the least
bit concerned – if anything, they sounded
bored.
“The SCP Foundation acts in accordance with
what this council dictates, not by whatever
moral framework you have chosen to impose
on this organization.”
“But the Devourer of Worlds is coming!”
Jace pleaded.
“You all know as much!
I’ve seen it in the SCP-2317 file; inevitable,
you used that exact word.”
“We are aware of the threat faced by SCP-2317-K,
or the Devourer as you call it,” a third
councilmember interjected.
“But rest assured, at the time 220 Calabasas
was established to provide an illusion of
containment, we calculated it would take several
decades for the final chain holding the creature
to give way.”
“That time might have already elapsed!”
the researcher argued.
“And in the meantime, we have no countermeasures
prepared, no strategy, and the rest of the
personnel have no idea that this threat is
coming.”
“Hmph, almost exactly the same wording as
last time,” one councilmember said, not
addressing the rest directly but still just
audible enough for Jace to detect it.
“What do you mean ‘last time’?” he
asked, thinking back a few short moments to
the beginning of this exchange.
“Wait, why did you say ‘hello again’
when I woke up here?”
There was a horrible, nauseating silence through
out the room for a moment.
Jace had already worked out the answer; why
would the Council bother telling him the truth
now?
“I’ve figured this out before, haven’t
I?” he said.
“A handful of times,” one of the voices
replied.
“If not you, then another member of personnel.
Every now and then someone snoops, uncovers
something they shouldn’t.”
“And you make them forget it,” Jace finished
their sentence for them.
“Before we apply the amnestics,” the voice
said.
“Observe: today’s 220 Calabasas procedure
is already underway.”
A huge, curved screen blinked to life; it
filled half the circumference of the room,
but wasn’t enough to give Jace any clearer
of a look at the O5 Council.
Each one of them was cast as shadowy, silhouetted
figures against the images now appearing on
the screen.
It was footage being streamed live from one
of the personnel cleared to enter SCP-2317.
They were already in the middle of performing
the phony ritual, spritzing holy water over
the seven pillars; unaware that only one of
them was still linked to a chain keeping the
Devourer imprisoned below.
Suddenly, there was a rumbling, a shaking
reverberating through the ground on the video
feed, like an earthquake...
or something moving underground.
“Oh my god,” Jace breathed as he watched
in horror.
“It’s happening!
The Devourer is coming now!
Get them out of there!”
Some of the O5s mumbled awkwardly to themselves.
“We shouldn’t act with too much haste,
it could just be the creature reacting to
the ritual,” one hypothesized.
“It’s been imprisoned for longer than
a lot of us have lived, it’s bound to get
restless,” another concurred.
“Besides, the security team are armed with
a nuclear device in case the worst should
happen.”
On the screen, the tremors were continuing.
The personnel member in charge of applying
the holy water dropped the silver aspergillum
and aspersorium containing it, spilling its
content over the salted earth below.
Without any further warning, the ground started
to crumble in the feed, an enormous clawed
hand bursting up from underground.
It was followed by the hulking shape of something
much larger breaking through the salt plain,
sending a tidal wave towards the personnel
member whose bodycam footage was being displayed.
The feed cut out, and the room was dark once
again.
“It’s too late,” Jace stared at the
council in a mix of terror and disgust.
“You did nothing, and now it’s too late!”
Before any of them could reply, another tremor
rang out, this time beneath Jace’s own feet.
The Devourer of Worlds was here.
It was bursting through the wooden door of
SCP-2317, and tearing the Foundation facility
apart with its immense size as it emerged.
The walls cracked, the entire building beginning
to crumble around him and the O5 Council,
who were all hurriedly exiting the chamber
to whatever plans or bunkers they had to ensure
their own personal survival.
Suddenly, the huge weight of something dropped
through the dark and collapsed on top of Jace.
Standing up among the wreckage of the obliterated
building, the Devourer of Worlds drew itself
up to its full height.
It was an impossibly-large creature, humanoid
and obese.
Its entire body was covered head-to-toe in
thick, armored scales, with horns atop its
jawless head.
From one of them hung the final chain, a withered
shackle no longer keeping the monster held
within its underground prison.
The seven chains had all failed.
The ritual, 220 Calabasas, had failed; in
fact, it never worked in the first place.
Far below, his arms pinned painfully under
a heavy slab of concrete, Jace stared up at
the towering form of the Devourer.
He had felt scared as the building came down
around him, and even now, there was a lingering
fear of his own death.
But there was something else there too, a
sense of feeling oddly relieved.
Not necessarily glad to be right about the
impending doom, or even pleased to know this
ancient, trapped deity was about to destroy
the whole planet.
But at least the Devourer of Worlds was honest,
he thought.
There was no subterfuge, no rituals acting
as a smokescreen, no more lies.
Just an honest, simplicity of a creature whose
only goal was to bring an end to everything.
As Jace watched, the Devourer raised its hands
up, reaching the highest pinnacle of the sky,
then brought them straight back down to Earth.
It plunged both deep into the skin of the
world, deep enough to crack the very surface
open, mantle and magma were spewing everywhere
like blood from the gaping wounds it left
in the planet.
Jace Jacobi closed his eyes, as the ground
beneath where he lay trapped ripped open,
he plummeted into the dark.
Now go and check out “SCP-2317 THE DEVOURER
OF WORLDS/A DOOR TO ANOTHER WORLD” and “SCP-2440
THE SEALED KING” for more eldritch horrors
that will destroy your mind!